veamos si podemos hacer alguna a un poco
más de práctica para tener más intuición
de lo que es el producto cruz que
estábamos viendo en el vídeo pasado y
aquí le seguimos en el último ejemplo
tomamos a cruz ven veamos qué sucede
cuando tomamos ave cruz
y voy a borrar algunas cosas de aquí
para am para tener más espacio y bueno
entonces vamos a ver qué pasa
borro esto esto de aquí no quiero
borrarlo todo porque vamos a necesitar
algunas cosas pero podríamos usar vamos
a borrar también esto y vamos a poder
usar otras cosas borro también este 25 y
bueno lo que lo que yo dibujé aquí fue a
cruz ve ajá entonces lo voy a separar
del resto de lo que tenemos aquí en la
pantalla y bueno para no confundirlos
entonces dibujo esta línea aquí que
separan y esto fue usado para la regla
de la mano derecha cuando yo intenté
hacer a cruz ve luego vimos que la
magnitud de esto fue de 25
n su dirección apuntaba hacia abajo
cuando lo dibujé yo aquí apuntaba hacia
dentro de la página entonces veamos qué
sucede cuando yo hago ve cruza solamente
estoy invirtiendo el orden así que ve
cruza bueno pues la magnitud va a ser la
misma porque aún tomaré la magnitud de b
por la magnitud de an por el seno del
ángulo entre ellos el cual fue pi sobre
6 radiales entonces seno de pi sobre 6
radiales luego multiplicó por algún
vector unitario n y bueno pero aquí será
lo mismo cuando yo multiplique
cantidades escalares no importa el orden
que en que las multiplico esto aún será
25 por algún vector n y aún sabemos que
ese rector n debe ser perpendicular a
ambos a y b y el hecho de que sea
perpendicular debe apuntar a la página
aquí ya sea hacia adentro o apuntando
hacia afuera entonces cuál es la
dirección luego tomamos nuestra mano
derecha y hacemos lo mismo que en el
vídeo pasado lo recuerdas pero recuerda
que también la dirección importa y
bastante
ahorita voy a ver mi hermano que el
mando se ve algo así la quiero dibujar
bien no quiero equivocarme ok entonces
bueno en este ejemplo si yo tomo mi mano
derecha tomo mi dedo índice en la
dirección del vector b y tomo mi dedo
medio en la dirección del vector a
entonces así va en la dirección del
vector ar y quedan dos dedos hacia
adentro de mi mano y entonces el pulgar
va en la dirección del producto cruz así
ahí está ahí hay un ángulo recto aquí
está el ángulo recto formado entonces en
este ejemplo esa es la dirección aquí
está la dirección del vector
y esta es la dirección del vector ven en
verde lo pongo hacia acá ambos están
haciendo ave cruza por eso yo tomo mi
dedo índice representando al vector b el
dedo índice obtiene el primer término el
dedo medio obtiene el segundo término y
el pulgar siempre obtiene la dirección
del producto cruz así que en este
ejemplo la dirección del producto cruz
es hacia arriba o en estas dos
dimensiones
aquí el producto cruz saldría de la
página para ver cruz and así que lo
dibujo en verde es el círculo con el
punto recuerda que eso fue como la punta
de la flecha saliendo y esto fue para la
cruz ven y ve cruzada es exactamente la
misma magnitud pero en la dirección
opuesta entonces eso es p cruz y
simplemente se voltea a la otra
dirección por eso debes usar tu mano
derecha porque quizás te paz o digas o
algo saldrá o entrar a la página
entonces bueno necesitas tu mano derecha
para ver si sale o entra de la página
pero bueno veamos si podemos tener un
poco más de intuición con otros ejemplos
así que vamos a ver de qué trata todo
esto porque como tú puedes ver todo esto
es cuestión de intuición y bueno
francamente te diré yo que el producto
cruz viene al uso en muchos conceptos
los cuales no tenemos mucha intuición
sobre ellos en la realidad tú sabes como
electrones atravesando un campo
magnético o el campo magnético en una
bobina muchas cosas que en la vida
diaria
ok bueno si viviéramos si viviéramos en
un campo magnético aunque bueno si
vivimos en un campo magnético pero si
quizás fuera un poco más fuerte
podríamos tener más intuición de todo
esto sin embargo bueno es difícil cuando
cuando no es así pero bueno sigamos para
entenderlo mejor pensemos en por qué
está este signo de teta ajá por qué no
simplemente multiplicamos las magnitudes
usamos la regla de la mano derecha y
averiguamos una dirección porque es
necesario usar el seno de teta por por
qué por qué por qué y bueno volver a
limpiar aquí borraré algunas cosas para
para tener más lugar entonces por qué
está ahí el seno de teta ahora dibujaré
otra vez algunos vectores los dibujaré
un poco más gruesos entonces este
digamos que es el vector
este es el vector am y aquí le pongo la
flecha acá está el vector b - siempre
debe ser más grande que a pero bueno
los pongo les pongo el nombre este está
este de aquí es el vector b y bueno
podríamos componer lo de diferentes
maneras es lo mismo magnitud de asse no
detectan magnitud debe obsceno de theta
por a ojalá no te esté confundiendo
simplemente te digo que que es lo mismo
no importa porque son magnitudes
entonces no importa el orden en el cual
las multiplicas podrías decir que esto
es a seno de teta multiplicado por la
magnitud de b
todo esto en la dirección del vector
normal entonces bueno queda así ahora
pensemos en qué es esto hace no detecta
qué es esto que éste está que es hace no
detecta que no es cateto opuestos sobre
hipotenusa entonces cateto opuestos
sobre hipotenusa lo escribo esto sería
la magnitud del vector ai también lo voy
a dibujar para que quede más claro todo
esto entonces dibujo aquí una línea
una línea de la herramienta aquí está la
línea y con esta línea aquí tenemos un
ángulo recto que se forma justamente
aquí entonces regresamos a la pregunta
ahora que ya tenemos formado el
triángulo rectángulo que es seno de teta
entonces bueno aquí tenemos el cateto
opuesto y el seno de teta es que todo
puesto sobre hipotenusa donde la
hipotenusa es la magnitud de a entonces
70 es igual a este lado el cual es el
cateto opuesto así que lo escribo sobre
cateto opuesto sobre la hipotenusa que
es la magnitud de a por lo tanto este
término a seno de teta es simplemente la
magnitud de esta línea muy bueno lo voy
a dibujar para entenderlo un poco mejor
vuelvo a dibujarlo no importa donde yo
inicié el vector lo único que interesa
aquí es la magnitud del vector así que
podemos decir que puedes mover los
vectores entonces este vector lo puedo
llamar yo el vector opuesto este vector
es lo mismo que este otro vector pero
como puedes ver simplemente lo estoy
trasladando entonces otra manera de
pensar
es como el componente del vector y
estamos acostumbrados a tomar un vector
y nombrarlo con dos componentes xy pero
ahora estamos tomando un vector a y lo
estamos nombrando con una componente
paralela al vector b y otra componente
que es perpendicular al vector b por lo
tanto hacen lo detentan es la magnitud
de la componente del vector a el cual es
perpendicular al vector b por lo tanto
hacen de teta es la magnitud de la
componente del vector a el cual es
perpendicular al vector b así que cuando
tomamos el producto cruz de dos números
lo que tú dices es que que no te importa
la magnitud total del vector a que es en
este ejemplo bueno lo que interesa es la
magnitud del vector a que es
perpendicular al vector b y esos son los
dos números que yo quiero multiplicar y
dar esa dirección especificada por la
regla de la mano derecha y bueno te voy
a mostrar algunas aplicaciones lo
usaremos en campos magnéticos por
ejemplo pero es importante que en sus
aplicaciones se encuentren los sectores
que son perpendiculares ya sea
una fuerza o a un radio porque bueno es
la razón por la que por la que el
producto cruz tiene un seno de teta si
observas esto como la magnitud de acero
de teta por b lo que nos dice es que
esta es la magnitud de la componente de
a perpendicular a b o podrías
interpretarlo como como la magnitud de a
por la magnitud de b seno de teta y esto
entonces en la teta y estoy aquí lo
pongo entre paréntesis luego podría
hacerlo de la otra manera podrías decir
bs no detecta esa componente de b que
que es perpendicular a también lo voy a
dibujar para que quede claro así que
este es mi vector y este es mi vector b
le pongo las puntas de las flechas y
también los nombró entonces la punta de
la flecha así y así este es
este es ve ve tiene una componente que
es perpendicular a amd y eso se mirará
am algo de esta manera aunque yo bueno
ya casi no tengo espacio así que lo voy
a dibujar mejor acá este es el vector
este es el vector b la componente debe
que es perpendicular al vector a se mira
algo así bueno voy a ponerlo en otro
color así que se mira algo así será
perpendicular ahí tendrá esta magnitud
aquí está un ángulo recto y ahora ya
puedes comprobar tú puedes ya comprobar
que la magnitud de este vector es de
seno de teta y de ahí viene la celo de
teta el cual asegura que no solamente
multiplicamos los vectores asegura que
multipliquemos las componentes de los
vectores que son perpendiculares a ellos
mismos para obtener un tercer vector que
es perpendicular a ambos vectores quien
haya inventado el producto cruz sabes
sabe que sigue siendo ambiguo porque
siempre habrá dos vectores que son
perpendiculares a los otros dos siempre
habrá uno que va hacia afuera y otro
hacia adentro así que van en dirección
contraria
entonces usamos la regla de la mano
derecha usamos la convención de usar la
mano derecha apuntando como una pistola
haces qué tus dedos todos queden
perpendiculares unos de otros y después
sabes cuál es la dirección que apunta el
otro vector y bueno espero no estés
confundido y te invito a ver el próximo
vídeo me gustaría mucho que lo vieras
haremos varios ejemplos